ich bin wirklich dumm oder so ich kurze
glaub sochtig bin und kann und D ich
mich D sprechen so verhalt hab der
Schwiz alle die gleiche Chance auf gute
schulbildig nicht alle die gich Chance
sicher nicht ich hab der Schul me Elter
hil ich hab kamppf dass ich h mit
trumjob machen und Journalistin bin also
wenn du richtig Name hast der Schwiz
oder nötige Geld dann hast du mehrance
noch Schulabschluss frage ich mich ob es
immer noch so ist oder ob sich da
richtig
chanceichheit genau das hätte ich
[Musik]
braucht ich
g Jahr zu Meer al Schul zurück ich bin
da als schülerinu worden und eigentlich
ist cool zu
und da aber ich weiß am erst Tag bin ich
so frustriert
ich wenn ich bliebe dann kann ich mir
brswunsch nicht machen ja und die hü
treff ich se Lehrer wo damals
mir kurz ist die Stufe im Kanton Z mit
der
[Musik]
Mittler mit Schul bin hat M Potenzial
erkannt da bist du gesassen bin ich da
bist du gesassen am ersten Schultag in
der SE D vor sind D sind mir Schulleiter
gestanden und hab die Schüler Schüler
begrüßt da also ich bin da frustriert
drinkckt
Jaag ja natürlich frustriert will du
will du ich B nicht
bist
bist also das kann sich
aber das ist das ist
Schulzimmer und da da ist aber da da
ichch Tisch also ziemlich
viel bra bra immer h
Ablagefläche jetzt noch so die ja ja
stimmt das ich GLB wirklich von Daus ich
DT ja
das
genek nur noch jünger ich bin schon
nicht so happy g dass ich jetzt in
daselandet bin ja aber du bist nicht die
einzig also es geht jedes Mal
geht's jedem Jahrgang wenn wenn der neue
J die se überk h natürlich so zu viel wo
wo ücht sind dass jetzt nur in der SEB
sind und dann jetzt aber die wo knapp
sind und den auch unter Druck stell oder
dass sie dann da bliebet eigentlich ich
gefü jetzt bin ich vom System
her oder dass man mich da h bringt obwoh
ich ja eigentlich n sogar auf der
KI
also ungerecht
od da und und so quasi W jetzt wenn
jetzt t zu für mich
also
du
dasade
Sekundarschule ja das von
mir ja ja
November n
zwis
zwischen genau super da da not ja aber
wenn jetzt
die ich was
ich
ja ja aber das ich ziemlichfü
was
dasstu ja genau ja da da Abteil
bisherige Zuteilung Abteilung B und den
noch Abteilung a ich emotional ich das
da geseh ja das glaube ich dir
[Gelächter]
ich das muss
man als Kind mit ander Muttersprach mit
Migrationshintergrund und mit Elter ohne
höcher Schulabschluss kann ich in min
wahnehmig meh m Leist als andere m Alter
h du dich schon mal
verwitcht dass du in Schulblade dankst
du vielleicht dankst oh der Schüler oder
die Schülerin bringt jetzt zu gar
nem ja also Schublade denken ich ich ich
ich immer vor oder und man ja auch also
erfahr wichtig pro
aber Manis ist ja auch für derfahig so z
Schublade denken also wenn du
jetztfahig beurteile ich jetzt das so
und so denn nochher wenn das festfahren
ist den dann könn das
schublad ich würde nicht sag schublad
aber dass ich Schüler dass ich Schü
bestimmte Situationen oder bestimmte
Phas falsch geschätzt haben das schon
natürlich das schon WST du sagen hab
alle die gleiche Chance nein nicht alle
die gleich Chance sicher nicht sicher
nicht sch rein vom was für mein elterus
kom sie was was hab sie was was K was
wie viel h den Elter die Heim wie viel
könen die Elter hen wie könen die Elter
nicht hen
ich meine du ter wo wo nichtwach sind du
ter wo
m also her schaffe dass dass sie dass
sie da könen
irgendwieister und und und sich
verdienen nein das sind die Chan die
sind verschieden immer
immerchü ja ja hören
[Musik]
tschüssfach Z Jahre
her ich hab mega Glück gehab mit meem
Lehrer also hät er mich nicht
motiviert und und ich hätte Gefühl ja me
ich hab ja irgendwie Gefühl doch ich kan
rie wenn ichm gut Z gut im Unterricht
mitmachen und dann auch lernen und die
prüf gut schrieben es hat viel mit dem
Lehrer zu und irgendwie hab ich Gefühl
dass jetzt da wirklich ich gut bicht
Glück Studie zeiget dass die meist
Kinder gich soziale Weg machen wie Elter
in
z 20% von kinderus bildf Familie
studiert der Kinder mit Akademiker Elter
sind 70% und dasich leistigge und gich
intellektuelle
Potenzial auf Instagram l Gucht Gefühl
sie Chance verpasst wie sie z wenigfdert
worden sind hat gemold und ich triff sie
jetzt
da ich kann sie sie von
mirachen
h hey so
langön Dorf und jetzt 20 jah später
krass Tochter genau das
ist ist Tochter von Buchhalterin und
Fabrikarbeit
der Primarch Schluss V ein Tag auf der
andere viel schlechter Noten
so schlecht dass sie schluss ist
unterste Level V der Oberstufe geschickt
worden ist und damals ist einf so D
Stu nicht großartig Möglichkeit
überhauptbildig machen
also da irg reinigungsfachfrau oder
Unterhalt
möglich oder
detailhandelsassistentin ja also m
extrem verzwielt siest hat okay mit dem
Entscheid ich
oberschul mE berufliche Karriere
besiegelt
damit aber denst dass sie zraut
sieerzieherin gemacht und dann sogar
Sozialpädagogik
studiert du h ja geschafft we ich das
nicht ein bewies dafür dases
bildingsystem mega durchläig und sch
gichhe um
ist ich glaube ehrlich gesag nicht
Chance gichheit
also das Problemem Schulsystem das ist
damals bei mir schon so gesie und ich
jetzt be me Tochter auch so dass du
einfach sofort in Schulblade gesteckt
wirst die L dich an und WN h wenn du
nicht Glück hast gute Lehrer hast l
jetzt nicht mal dich sondern l einfach
der schulbricht vom letzte Lehrer und
dann bist du schon direkt in der
Schublade
und hab nicht Gefühl ist praktisch
unmöglich und das finde ich einfach das
dar Land wie der Schwiz einfach nicht
sie wirklich nicht das finde finde ich
ziemlich erschreckend dass das noch
immer so ist und dass
daslar wird also wenn du richtig Name
hast der Schwiz od
nötige Geld dann hast du mehr schance
als wenn du sag jetzt mal Arbeiter
familiest oder wenn blöd ausländis nam
hast dann
h oder halt nicht so ausgeseh wie wie
wie dass sie sich das vorstell oder dich
nicht so verhalt wie sie sich das
vorstellt ja dass das dass das in der
Schwiz so immer nch ist das finde ich
schon ziemlich bedenklich ehrlich ich
frage mich wo das no herführe also wenn
das schon über Generationen so
sot
wird glücklich sie ist verantwortlich
für der Empfang auf dem großen
Campingplatz was mus machen ich muss
jetzt DAV zu r
undat ma
zum Tochter von
derira hat nach der obligatorische
Schulzeit kelussö und hilft drum da auf
dem
Campingplatz wie ihr
Lehrerin und Lehrer unterschätzt und ih
Fähigkeiten abgesprochen was sie das hat
man sogar
abklären das ist
so sag
so mit so fachmut und so wo sie Test hab
jetzt ob ich könte oder nicht und
ich
Problem und
zch
hatvertrau dumm oder so
Kur bin und kann und ich michpr so
verhal h du Gefühl wenn Du mir Leist
bringen dann hätte Dich gar nicht so
behandelt
ja sch
wenn normal behandelt W W Klass a dass
ich dann vielleicht viel mehr könen
leisten als jetzt also dust eigentlich
Schuld bei dir jetzt nicht oder wie
verstah ich das also weiß wenn man so
gehört die Geschicht dann überle man
sich ja schon hey h duicht sber irendwi
Schulter ja also was ich danke was ich
sch Schulter bin sch Sturheit
ichog einfach wie so ma
und oder
so
mir
[Musik]
alles vergiss wie
vorher
gr mittlerwe hat sie gute Neuigkeiten
n im
[Musik]
detailhandelang
Schul Tochter ist nicht ganz so einfach
ja das ist so also wir schwierigigen
Schulstart kognitiv überhaupt nicht auf
dem Stand von dem was also haben wir
entwicklspsychologische Test
Kinderspital gemacht sie abgeklärt Word
auf
ADHS und und und also alles was elich V
verlangt gemacht alles wiederlecken also
die Test alle das nicht so wie das
hergestellt wird man ist einfach
machtlos oder wenn man wenn man
irgendwie dir wenn dir git wird di Kind
ist stumm und di Kind wird nie zu
irgendeeten
bringen und und du machst alles zum
irgendwie Zee hey es ist im Fall nicht
so und egal was du machst dir wird
einfach die ganze Zeit wier oder dem
Kind wird die ganze Zeit du bist dumm du
bist nicht wert du
das tut weh das tut richtig richtig weh
nein h nicht
also ich bin mega froh
hat machen und es berührt mich we ich
gehört wie als Jugendliche
Angst
zwifel genau gewsst hat dass L nicht sie
glaub und ihr das Potenzial nichtind und
das giche passiert dann
ih Tochter und sie muss noch mal
kamppfen und noch mal
ze das da Potenzial drin steckt das
wast
cherechtigkeit Bundesverfassung
verankert J soll die gich Chance auf
bildig egal wel Herkunft will sprach
oder finanzielle
Möglichkeit aber iche schon Gefühl dass
es für die schwerer ist für mich
Strang
in der ich dann der Druck geh zum gute
Noten machen damit ich dann nicht ins B
und manchmal ich mich ehlich allein
gefühlt we z.B be der H ich nicht meine
Elter ob sie da sie schlicht und einfach
gar nicht aufgaben verstanden hab und
ich habe mir das Angebot gewünscht W ich
h freiwillig kostenlos W hätte Frage
stellen und mittlerweile gibt so
Angebot bitania ist gerade so Angebot
drin wo sie unterstützt wird und sie
triff ich
jetzt pitania ist 15 und wohnt mit der
Familie im kantonargau die Mutter ist
Verkäuferin und ihre Vater ist
Automechaniker sie sind in Eritrea und
in ethiopi aufgewachsen das Schlafzimmer
ja genau ab und zu sie der Schul nicht
ganz n drum HT sie mittwochn auchm her
und
lernt ist sie früh Granze also nach der
Schu W ich
z.B bin und das noch malt hab bin ich
nach so ich verstanden was es g und bin
Hal stundenang dass
ich ich bin blöd vor bin ich wirklich
die einzige wo das jetzt nicht verstand
oder g so ich habe mich auch hilflos
gefühlt iche nicht ter und ich kan
einfach g sagen ja Mami PAP ich check
das nicht kan mir das kurz erklären
sondern ich habe m selber
duf ich gespüre pitania ist Schü drum
wundert mich auch nicht dass sie der
klass will zeigen wenn sie im
unterrichtis nicht verstanden hat mir
ist es gich Gang B schlechte Note
zwifelt sie an sich selber wenn ich nach
so Ergebnis gesehen dann bin ich nachher
mit mir selber auch nichtfed will ich
weiß dass ich mE kan und vor allem finde
ich auch dass mich dass mir aus macht
dass ich gut in der Schul bin dass ich
viel lern und vor allem auch gut die
Note hol und wenn ich wie das verlür
dann verlüre ich mir auch m
ich sie möcht mal studierere und drum
unbedingt ist gemie vor allem wie meine
Elter wo sie da Job gesucht H ist nicht
l ich auch mit sie auch ke zusag be und
ich
denke die Angst auch li V dem dass ich
dass alle offen
sind Chance vit auf der bildw aber nicht
sehr gut Studie von der Uni zür hat
aufzeigt dass Kinder a einfach
Verhaltnis in der primarschul schlechter
benutet werdet als Kinder von
privilegierte Familie und drum
schlechter die Chance
über hat halb so viele Cousinen wie
Benny geh2 ja wür ich auch
sagen hatberandelt und hat sich
fürsprogramm sch sie ist gerade auf
worden das wird da im Bade V privat
Spender vom lotterief und der Schule
unterstützt
bringt
ich mich V der SCH
verbesser Frage kann ich immer wiederage
ich weniger Angst fr sind ja das da und
ich habe auch allgemein
verbesser Ziel von dem Programm ist dass
es arbeiterker a bescheidene finanzielle
Verhältnis oder mit
Migrationshintergrund schaff oder in
anspruchsv Le genau das hätte ich
braucht das wirkich ein Lehrer oder
Lehrerin mir und das
ich
w ja lern und wenn ich Frage dass ich zu
gerade immer im
Schulzimmer
verstim mit der Familie redet Amis und
ich
Z wenn man nicht gut deutsch kann ist
man eben auch nicht gut in den Fächern
die allgemein bilden sind oder auch in
Physik oder Chemie man scheitert dann
eigentlich am Deutsch also ist nicht so
einfach
nein wenn man unterstütz braucht dann
heißt das
nicht das mir das man dumm ist ich hätte
die unterstützbucht will ich ganz klar
Defizit kan ich
mutterprach w schwiut ist nämlich Tamil
und es hat viel Zusatz BR zum alle
Aufgabe Verst in der Schu undm hätte ich
mir ja mit braucht heißt aber nicht dass
ich wenig Potenzial oder für weniger
nicht
[Musik]
W das ist jetzt
sozusagen das Motorrad mit dem du
Richtung Gymnasium
fährst wenn ich bitania beobachte dann
ich mich it auch
B ja Wiederer Kanne will ich so sch bin
und ja so viel will zum Zee hey dass ich
eigentlich meh kan als was andere danket
und ich weiß noch me Vater hat mir immer
gesagt hey ich kauf dir jedes Buch wo du
WST wenn du W lernen dann du nicht das
ermögliche und auf die andere Seite hab
ich genau GewSt hey die finanzielle l
meine Elter
das ermöglicht gar nicht es macht mir
auf jeden Fall mega Freud dass jetzt
bitania so Angebot hat und und sie sich
entfalten und ja dass man sie auch seht
dass man ihr auch vermittelt hey mir
unterstützen Dich und m sind was du h
und du kan eigentlich me was denkst du
was h du für erfahr gemacht in
Schulkarriere sch mir doch Komment und
viel mal dass du da bis DAH GLT hast